[Musik]
wir werden immer älter
einige finden wir werden zu alt und sie
entscheiden sich mit hilfe einer
sterbehilfeorganisation geplant aus dem
leben zu scheiden
nicht alle die das tun sind vorher auch
krank sondern einige davon sind einfach
lebens satt doch ist es ein guter grund
aus lebens seit dem suizid zu begehen
und dürfen wir einander auch helfen den
suizid zu begehen nur bei menschen
lebensart sind darüber diskutiere ich
heute mit saskia frei sie ist
rechtsanwältin und sie ist die
präsidentin vom exit deutsche schweiz
und ich diskutiere mit roland kunz ist
chefarzt am spital affoltern für
geriatrie und für palliativmedizin frau
frei exit zählt mittlerweile über 78.000
mitglieder wäre unsere welt eine bessere
welt wenn wir alle mitglieder einer
sterbehilfeorganisation würden
das kann ich nicht beantworten für mich
selber ist es aber sich wichtig dass man
sich in den guten zeiten die man halt
gedanken darüber macht jetzt vielleicht
einmal ist wenn die zeiten für jemanden
seien nicht mehr so gut sind wenn man
sich gedanken darüber macht was soll ich
ihnen eine patientenverfügung schreiben
wenn man sich gedanken darüber macht wie
sehe ich mein lebensende wo ist für mich
die lebensqualität und wohl nicht mehr
herr kunst sie sind nicht mitglied von
exit machen sie sich keine gedanken über
ihr lebensende
doch so häufig bin ja eigentlich in
meiner tätigkeit mit konfrontiert und
ich vertrage auftragen seite darauf bin
ich schwer krank bin dass die
palliativmedizin bis dann doch weiter
ausgebaut ist nicht gut betreut werden
und auf der anderen seite versuche ich
in meinem ganzen leben auch eine haltung
zu leben dass ich auch gewisse dinge
geschehen lassen und um versuche
anzunehmen so wie sie geschehen auf
reisen sagen ja eigentlich ist ein
beitritt zu einer sterbehilfe und
erziehung so etwas wie eine versicherung
sie kostet 45 franken im jahr bei exit
was fehlt denn her kunst oder was würden
sie ihm sagen warum soll
beitreten das kann ich ihm gar nicht
sagen das wird der grund selber wissen
denn für das was für ihn vielleicht
wichtig ist eben eine patientenverfügung
zu machen
da muss noch nicht mitglied einer
sterbehilfeorganisation sein aber wir
wissen von unseren mitglied und die zum
teil schon über 30 jahre dabei sind dass
das menschen sind die sich natürlich
noch viel vermehrt mit sich selber mit
der gesundheit mit der einstellung zum
leben mit der einstellung zur medizin zu
hochleistungsmedizin zur frage muss man
alles was man kann eben selber oder gibt
es auch die möglichkeit zu sorgen
es ist zwar technisch möglich mein leben
noch so und so zu verlängern aber ist
das für mich doch qualität oder nicht
das sind die fragen die unsere
mitglieder beschäftigt und die natürlich
dann auch dazu führen dass man sich
vertieft mit dem thema vertrauen gemacht
also ich habe eigentlich noch einmal so
richtig tief nachdenken tun vor allem
die mitglieder von exit was sagen sie
dazu
ich würde eigentlich eher das gegenteil
behaupten also ich finde eine sicherung
gibt einem jahr als ein vielleicht auch
falsches gefühl von sicherheit
wenn ich etwas nicht versichern kann
dann muss ich mich persönlich gedanken
darüber machen wie gericht damit um was
bedeutet das wie kann ich mich darauf
vorbereiten dass man im alltagsleben und
wieder auf wenn es um eine absicherung
geben wenn ich eine besicherung habe
dann muss ich mich eigentlich nicht mehr
darum kümmert dann habe ich nämlich die
versicherung
ich glaube das ist eigentlich das
problem dass wenn alle eine solche
versicherung abschließen dass sie sich
dann eigentlich viel weniger damit
auseinandersetzen dass das leben
bedeutung was das bedeuten kann ihr
leben natürlich das gegenteil wir so
unsere mitglieder die sich mit diesem
thema vertraut gemacht haben sorgen im
wesentlichen für als grund für den ball
tritt überhaupt ich bin froh dass ich
weiß dass ich ihn notfalls exit
zurückgreifen kann ich bin froh dass es
doch es gibt hoffe natürlich sprache
tauss nie weil ihr alle wünschen uns ja
dass wir eines tages hochbetagt und
gesunden verein schlafen können
aber diese
versicherungsmodell wie sie es jetzt
erwähnen das gibt einem die beruhigung
für den notfall und wir haben viele
zuschriften von mitglied und die sorgen
dadurch kann ich so auch die beschwerden
des alters betrogen und aushalten weil
ich weiss ja im hinterkopf im notfall
ist nicht das mal davon gebrauch machen
will
aber man könnte wenn man wollte das ist
die philosophie wenn wir über die
landesgrenzen hinaus schauen dann ist es
im moment so dass in deutschland sehr
viel jetzt wieder über suizidbeihilfe
diskutiert wird war eine gruppe von
juristen ethikern und medizinern
darunter auch gian domenico borasio oder
auch schon hier in der sendung war mit
uns über das sterben diskutiert hat die
haben ein ein gesetzentwurf eingereicht
die eben auch in deutschland den ärzten
zur hilfe in zukunft erlauben soll im
moment ist es noch verboten wenn sie
über die landesgrenze schauen erfüllt
sie das mit stolz finde das eine gute
sache wenn das modell schweiz schule
macht ich glaube sie beurteilen die
situation etwas zu euphorisch bis heute
wäre es in deutschland rechtlich ja so
dass die suizidbeihilfe und sich nicht
strafbar wäre
nur den ärzten ist wieder strom das
recht verboten das rezept für das sterbe
mittel das natrium pentobarbital konkret
gesorgt auszufüllen und das ist das
bisher bekannteste und sanfte sterbe
mittel das wir haben also die deutsche
ärzteschaft ist sehr sehr von den
standesregeln geleitet weil diese haben
im gegensatz zu uns gesetzeskorrektur
und es sind in deutschland bestrebungen
im gange
die sterbehilfe generell zu verbieten
das ist die tendenz in deutschland und
in österreich im übrigen genau das
gleiche den bestrebungen im gange die
sterbehilfe auf verfassungsebene zu
verbieten und in deutschland auch noch
dazu
die mitgliedschaft einer
sterbehilfeorganisation das ist dann
auch verboten und die organisation
selber also da bin ich noch gar nicht so
sicher was da immer ein bisschen
rohmaterials angestoßen sie ist
angeschaut wird auch darüber die
gespannt was ist
in welche richtung ist das ist noch
keineswegs gesorgt dass das in eine
liberalere richtung geht als alles was
jetzt schon weh aber noch einmal die
frage auch an sie ist die schweiz ein
vorbild mit der liberalen regelung die
die haben
ich glaube ich würde die frage ist es
weiter fassen ich finde es geht ja nicht
nur um diesen begleiteten suizid sondern
überhaupt wie setzen wir uns mit der
frage der sterbehilfe passiven
sterbehilfe der unterlassung von
lebensverlängernder maßnahmen
auseinander und wenn wir in die
nachbarländer schauen dann tun sie sich
eben halt mit dieser thematik nach wie
vor schwer und das hat mit der
geschichte zu tun
und in dieser beziehung sind wir
vielleicht etwas haben wir einen einen
eine andere voraussetzungen mit diesem
thema umzugehen dass unsere geschichte
natürlich nicht belastet ist mit der
gleichen situation wie interessen und in
gesprächen die alternative party
das hat sich aber eben ganz viel
erzähler lässt sich mit beteiligten aus
dem was damals geschehen ist
das hat dazu geführt dass dann das
pendel nach dem krieg ganz extrem in die
andere richtung ausgeschlagen ist und
gesagt hat
jedes leben ist wertvoll und muss
erhalten werden und eine diskussion über
ein sterben lassen geschweige denn über
einen begleiten eines sterbenden beim
suizid als worten absolut tabu
vielleicht sagen das ist absolut richtig
und so auch das ist die vergangenheit
und hier vielleicht auch noch die
politische hintergrund situation wir in
der schweiz mit unserer direkten
demokratie habe ich auch nicht nur die
möglichkeit alle vier jahre
mitglieder eines parlamentes zu wählen
sondern wir haben dort initiative und
referendum direkte einflussmöglichkeiten
auf die materielle ausgestaltung einer
vorlage und ost ist in deutschland ja
nicht so in deutschland wäre die
bevölkerung wenn man sie fragt und das
ist sie gefragt worden
275 der sterbehilfe zustimmend gegenüber
eingestellt das nutzt aber nichts weil
sie keine direkten einflussmöglichkeiten
haben wenn ich aber trotzdem noch einmal
darüber sprechen vorbild schweiz dann
ist macht sich schnell auch beim
sogenannten sterbetourismus um den
großbritannien
dann sagt man dass die wendung going to
switzerland eigentlich gleichgesetzt
wird mit der idee man geht in die
schweiz um suizid beihilfe in anspruch
zu nehmen und im jahr 2012 sind im
kanton zürich 172 menschen so gestorben
also touristen oder personen aus dem
ausland in die schweiz gekommen sind um
hier zu sterben ist das ein
zweifelhafter ruf den die schweiz da
habt ein sterbe touristisches land zu
sein
ich finde das sehr also ich merke dass
wenn ich in unsere nachbarländer geht
also ich natürlich immer darauf
angesprochen werde
dass viele meiner kollegen zum beispiel
in österreich über diese entwicklung
schockiert sind uns sich fragen ja
machen wir nichts dagegen lassen wir das
einfach so geschehen auf der langen zeit
ist natürlich die ganze geschichte
sterbetourismus an sich wirklich ein
problem aus meiner sicht das hat nichts
mehr mit beziehung zu tun sondern das
ist dann wirklich nur noch eine eine
service und dienstleistung die hebräer
erbracht wird nicht ob das sehr
problematisch wenn ich darauf möchte ich
doch ein bisschen noch verständnis
wecken für diese menschen die da vom
ausland anreisen persönlich finde ich
den begriff sterbetourismus kommt seine
über das weckt so ein falsches gefühl
von ferien vieles kann ja wohl keine
rede sein wenn ein schwer leidende
mensch und trinken frauen von größten
behinderungen und schwierigsten
umständen ihren die schweiz gereist um
hier das vollziehen zu können was ihm in
seinem heimatstaat von natürlich ein
bisschen die parallele zum ausdruck des
abtreibungs tourismus den wir ja von der
schweiz in die niederlande hatten auch
bei uns die abtreibung noch verboten war
aber deshalb sind wir natürlich alle
berechtigte wir begleichen kann er
ausländer wir sind darauf fokussiert ihr
in der schweiz wohnhaften personen
hilfeleistungen anzubieten
dann aber ist es egal ob jemand
schweizer ist oder ausland einfach
unsere strengen abklärungen die seo
einer sterbebegleitung braucht zurecht
weil sterbebegleitung erträgt keine
fehler das verstellt sich auch von
selbst könnte mir so nicht gewährleisten
wenn ihr dann vielleicht sogar noch vor
dem ausland abklärungen treffen müssen
das liegt für uns nicht drin und wir
finden aber schon auch es ist natürlich
auch an den menschen in den jeweiligen
ländern dass sie ihr engagement für
diese sache zeigen und auch versuchen
einfluss zu nehmen auf die dortigen
gesetzlichen vorgaben und vielleicht
auch die politiker zu diesem thema
befragen um dann eine auswahl zu haben
wenn wähle ich das nächste mal
und wen nicht aber gegen das wort
tourismus muss ich offen sagen da
verwahre ich mich dagegen das ist ein
unschönes worden
und vielleicht sollten wir noch ergänzen
der ordnung halber dass es die statistik
weist doch bei exit auch vier personen
aus die in dieser zeit ausländerinnen
ausländer waren die mit exit gestorben
sind aber sie haben im vorfeld auch
gesagt dass das person waren diese
allein in der schweiz geübt haben die
mitglieder weisen so recht und da hier
mitglied wo denn sie waren schweizer
sind dann ins ausland vielleicht
gegangen und wieder zurückgekommen aber
sie sind vom ausland her zurückgekommen
das war ganz wenige ich glaube bis in
2012 etwa waren ist in den vergangenen
fünf sechs jahren zurück etwa vier
personen glauben da haben sie sich jetzt
ist es ja so wir haben jetzt über fälle
gesprochen sterbetourismus wenn ich
diesen begriff doch noch einmal benutzen
darf
bei denen die menschen todkrank sind es
sind meistens menschen mit einer
fortgeschrittenen krebserkrankungen oder
mit schweren neurologischen erkrankungen
die dann hier her kommen sehr viel zu
reden gab in letzter zeit aber gar nicht
diese art von suizid beihilfe sondern
das sogenannte bilanz suizid oder der
alter so erzählt also menschen die eben
gesund sind und die irgendwann sagen mir
reicht's ich bin so alt ich habe jetzt
keine lust mehr weiterzuleben der bilanz
suizid ist für ärzte und ärztinnen eine
spezielle herausforderung herkunft was
haben sie zu diesem phänomen
grundsätzlich finde ich das was mich am
meisten beschäftigt ist aber nicht was
welches menschenbild steckt dahinter
dass wir überhaupt über diese bilanz
zieht oder diesen sieben sat1 suizid
diskutieren im gegensatz zu den
bisherigen suizidfällen von menschen die
schwer krank waren die vielleicht
ebenso ende waren wo wirklich eine
medizinische komponente ganz klar da ist
sind das eigentlich situationen wo wir
von einer sozialen komponente sprechen
und deshalb finde ich sagt problematisch
die ganze diskussion die jetzt läuft
welche rolle haben die ärzte bei diesem
ort suizid wie wir machen aus einer
sozialen integration die medikalisierung
wir und machen sie doch am schluss zu
einer medizinischen indikation und das
ist glaubt falsch aber ist soziales
leiden weniger schlimm für einen arzt
als körperliche tragen nein das finde
ich ist ein wichtiges phänomen aber um
das soziale leiten und dafür
verantwortlich ist war unsere
gesellschaft und nicht der mediziner ist
darf nicht etwas das dem medikament
lösen können und deshalb will ich es ist
dringend nötig dass wir das auftrag
gesellschaftlichen ebene diskutieren und
nicht in westliche darüber diskutieren
welche rolle haben die ärzte bei dieser
art von suizid
sie werden sagen bilanz suizid ist ein
phänomen das zustande kommt aufgrund
eines defizits dass wir haben in unserer
gesellschaft verständlich richtig ja ich
finde es hat sich eine eine negative
werthaltung entwickelt gegenüber allem
was nicht mehr unseren
leistungsansprüchen entspricht also dass
wir autor und überhaupt unsere nirgendwo
leben den wert unseres lebens und
unserer leistungsbereitschaft und
fähigkeit messen wenn diese nachlässt
dass wir dann diesem leben nicht mit dem
gleichen wert beimessen das finde ich
eigentlich unter die grundproblematik
dahinter exit befürworteten akerson city
haben die statuten im letzten mai
geändert um dieses diesem phänomen
rechnung zu tragen
wie kam es denn dazu und was sagen sie
zu diesen vorwürfen spiel vielleicht
auch vorstellen wieder die klärung die
muss einfach immer wieder seien es gibt
missverständnisse die darf noch nicht
stehen lassen
es geht mir darum gesunde menschen beim
sterben zu begleiten
wer gesund ist der wir leben der will
nicht sterben und zwar ob alt oder jung
ist es völlig egal
es geht darum beim thema alter sowie
zieht so wie das von unseren senioren in
der vereinigung vorgebracht wurde dass
man den versuch unternehmen will
menschen die nicht an einer tödlichen
krankheit
genauer an einer vielzahl von
verschiedenen gebrechen oder gepressten
welche für den einzelnen direkt
betroffen eben ebenfalls eine
unzumutbare bleiben situation hervorruft
dass diese menschen einen erleichterten
zugang zum sterbe mittel bekommen sollen
und zwar dass sie nicht die vielleicht
die gleichen gesundheitsprüfungen über
sich ergehen lassen müssen wie ein
50-jähriger es kommt da noch der
psychosoziale das psycho soziale element
dazu wenn also jemand der vielleicht
eben über 90 ist hoch betagt kommt knopf
noch seinen haushalt bewältigen hat
verschiedene gepressten sehstörungen
gleichgewichtsstörungen und jetzt kommt
noch ein oberschenkelhalsbruch hinzu er
ist im spital und man eröffne die klage
werde nie mehr nach hause gehen sondern
jetzt stünde eigentlich der eintritt ins
pflegeheim bevor und das ist etwas was
dieser mensch nie wollte da sehe ich
eigentlich nicht an wie soja und diese
menschen vorschreiben soll das musst du
jetzt halt auch noch aushalten
das kannst du nicht selber entscheiden
video das leben weiterführen oder eben
beenden schreiben sie dass ihre
nationale wurde das gerade sorgen dass
schreibt eigentlich niemand diesen
menschen vor ich bin auch ganz klar der
meinung dass jeder mensch wirklich für
sich ganz allein entscheidet was er
tragen will und was nicht nur an seine
grenzen setzen
das respektieren wir aber was mich eben
wirklich so nachdenklich gemacht ich bin
seit 33 jahren in der geriatrie tätig
vor 30 jahren sind die menschen in die
langzeitpflege als ins pflegeheim
eingetreten
und wenn man die noch besser
mobilisieren wurde physiotherapie machen
und so weit haben viele dieser alten
leute gesagt wissen sie das ganze leben
habe ich gearbeitet und jetzt möchte ich
mal ein bisschen genießen können jetzt
möchte ich mich bedienen lassen können
und die leute sind zwar gern in die
institution gekommen weil sie das gefühl
hatten wie ich hatte keine ferien und
jetzt kann ich mag das feeling von
ferien genießen
ich weiß dass ich nicht mehr kann das
wird mir abgenommen das wird gemacht
und innerhalb von 30 jahren ist das ein
völlig negatives bild geworden dass
jeder sagt das ist die hohen vision
irgendwann pflegeheim gehen zu müssen
irgendwann sich helfen lassen müssen von
anderen menschen
und da frage ich mich was ist dass wir
eine entwicklung und sind wir schon im
winter entwickelt sich das eben immer
mehr in diese richtung
interessant ist ja auch dass die
zeitschrift reformiert gerade kürzlich
eine umfrage gemacht hatte wurde vor
rund zwei wochen publiziert eine
repräsentative umfrage in der 68 prozent
der schweizerinnen und schweizer sich
für einen erleichterten zugang zum
suizid also zur suizidbeihilfe
ausgesprochen haben für betagte menschen
also es scheint tatsächlich diese
bewegung zu geben
aber ich finde sie haben vorhin ein
bisschen verharmlost frau frey sie haben
gesagt es geht nicht darum gesunde
menschen
es geht ja aber was heißt denn krank im
auto also gewisse gepressten zu haben
vielleicht müde zu sein vielleicht
steife gelenke zu kriegen ist das denn
schon konkret ist ich würde so definiert
sie sind jetzt noch in einem alter wo
man sagt mir geht's gut ich bin fit ich
meinen alltag gut bewältigen
je älter wir werden je mehr akzeptieren
wir unsere einschränkungen auch ein 60
jähriger mensch ist nicht mehr so topfit
wie ein 30-jähriger und das ist auch
okay so das ist ja ganz normal und ein
80-jähriger oder ein 90 jähriger habe
wieder andere einschränkungen
hinzunehmen
die für ihn noch akzeptabel sein können
aber jetzt gibt es doch wirklich
einschränkungen wo jeder mensch für sich
selber sorgen muss dass es für mich
nicht wenn der 90-jährige hochbetagte
sein leben lang gerne gelesen hat das
gibt es nämlich und plötzlich ist das
augenlicht gefährdet weil es einfach
krankheiten gibt die das augenlicht
beschlagen können und dazu kommen auch
noch körperliche einschränkungen und
dann eben weil er nicht mehr selber zu
hause leben kann steht der eintritt ins
pflegeheim es gibt nur diese lösung dann
sehe ich persönlich nicht ein wieso
dieser mensch nicht sagen kommt für mich
stimmt es nicht mehr meine
lebensqualität bei
nicht ihre und auch nicht die vom herrn
küren so gar nicht meine um die geht es
nicht es geht um immer die individuelle
lebensqualität die für den betroffenen
gericht stehen und sie bringen jetzt
noch einmal ein beispiel mit einem
pflegeheim sie haben vorhin gesagt
tatsächlich ist die angst groß abhängig
zu sein in der pflege diese diese
menschen möchten da nicht hingehen
glauben sie hat etwas zu tun mit der
gesellschaft oder hat er so etwas zu tun
mit der qualität der pflege institution
sind wir da einfach auch einen gewissen
back löschung nicht mehr up to date ich
habe mit beiden zu tun einerseits die
gesellschaftliche entwicklung merkt man
nur schon wenn man die bezeichnungen
betrachten früher waren das krankenheim
pflegeheime die patienten betreut haben
heute sind die seniorenresidenzen die
klienten betreuen
aus dem spital ist das
gesundheitszentrum geworden als vielen
krankenkassen wurden gesundheitskassen
also das ist so die gesellschaftliche
seite dass wir eigentlich immer mehr
diese seite irgendwo tabuisieren das
auch krankheit und einschränkungen
pflegebedürftigkeit dazu gehört und das
ist ein 2 das habe ich das das andere
problem das natürlich heute auf
politischer ebene viel mehr über kosten
diskutiert wird als über die qualität in
der betreuung alter menschen und ich
finde das ganz bezeichnung das gibt im
moment ja diese nationale strategie
demenz die vom bund und mit den kantonen
erarbeitet wurde wir hatten kürzlich ein
hearing mit unserem
gesundheitsdirektorin toyota gesagt das
ist sache der gemeinden eine gute
betreuung entsprechend dem was dann
wirklich die patienten und ihre
angehörigen brauchen anzubieten
wenn ich mit gemeindepolitikern spreche
sprechen die nur über den steuerfuss in
ihrer gemeinde und klagen über die
allgemeinen kosten die sonst zu
bewältigen sind und wenn sie noch ganz
weit gehen dann schaffen sie irgend ein
altes konzept das in einer schublade
dann verschwindet also fonds gibt druck
auf die pflegeheime es gibt nicht das
geld brauchte dann schau arbeitet man
mit einem tieferen schlüssen und
qualifizierten personal wird sich
tatsächlich die qualität
also zugespitzt werden sie sagen
suizidbeihilfe im alter ist ein problem
von ökonomischen ressourcen knapp werden
wenn sie so zuspitzen
nein so stark zuspitzen würde ich es
nicht aber es kann dazu führen dass es
missbraucht wird für das treffen und
nicht ja wenn wir dieses problem der
finanzierung haben dann ist es für mich
als politiker vielleicht ganz sinnvoll
wenn ich diese bestrebungen unterstützen
weil es mir dann beiläufig auch ein
anderes problem löst ich glaube wir
müssen wieder bei den fakten bleiben im
gegensatz zu früher vor 30 jahren vor 50
jahren auch da wurden ja auch noch nicht
so alt wie wir es heute werden also die
medizin hat riesige fortschritte gemacht
die frau gestern immer ist das noch die
lebensqualität für mich wenn ich euch
auch 120 werden könnte mit irgendwelchen
hilfsmitteln dass muss auch jeder für
sich bei und was weiß ich nicht aber bei
den pflegeheimen frühgeborenes
altersheime da ist man tatsächlich so
kann sich mit dem erreichen des ahv
alters in mit dem körper schönen
erschienen und gesagt ich würde jetzt
das zimmer beziehen
im alter sei wo meine mutter betreut
wurde bis zum ende hat es noch einen
großen sorge hat dass
tanzveranstaltungen gegeben dass man das
ist so aber heute ist der eintritt ins
pflegeheim es gibt ja keine reinen
altersheime mehr sind alters und
pflegeheime ist weit über ruft sie in
der regel die leute kommen erst gar
nicht mehr oben das geld weil der mensch
hat vielleicht seine bedürfnisse auch
geändert er möchte gerne zu hause alt
werden werde immer möglich in den
gewohnten vier wänden und das ist die
allergie team rang spruch den man den
unterhalt und demgemäß sind natürlich in
den heutigen pflegeheimen da ist das
wetter gibt es keine gesunden betrag den
menschen die dort ein drehen so etwas
wieder an dass wir sehr viel älter
werden ja runter machen haben sie auch
gesagt die versicherung die bezieht sich
auch darauf davon unter umständen
gewisse behandlungen nicht mehr möchte
und das gefühl hat man kann sich dem
nicht entziehen und sie ist tatsächlich
so dass es viele studien gibt die zeigen
dass ärzte selber für sich weniger
therapien in anspruch nehmen im alter
sie nehmen weniger aggressive therapien
in anspruch und sie verzichten auf mehr
dinge
das zeigen verschiedene studien die in
den usa publiziert wurden warum ist das
denn so wenn ärzte für sich selber
gewisse therapien gar nicht möchten
warum werden sie denn den patienten
verschrieben oder anna bozen oder
aufgezwungen ich weiß es nicht es hat
wahrscheinlich sehen wie mit den
erwartungen zu tun mit denen der mensch
eben gegenüber unserer medizin auftritt
das ist auch wenn sie schauen was wird
in den medien auf dem fernsehen
präsentiert das sind immer die neuesten
und modernsten therapien und darüber
wird eine sendung gemacht und damit
wickeln wir an ich höre hohe erwartungen
bei den patienten und entsprechend ist
es wahrscheinlich für viele menschen
schwierig überhaupt realistisch
einzuschätzen was ihre möglichkeiten sie
in was ihr profit von einer therapie
sind ist und für die ärzte
die sind da realistisch weil sie das
einschätzen können aufgrund des
fachwissens und ich glaube da sind wir
beim kern der ganzen diskussion
es geht nicht nur um selbst
verantwortung bezüglich dem eigenen tod
für sich entscheiden kann wann ich
sterben will die fängt viel früher haben
dass ich mir aber überlegt welche
therapie will ich auch und lebe ich ja
ja und also patientenverfügung da wären
sie durchaus da vier patienten führer
ist etwas ganz wichtiges gut auch wenn
ich 80 bin und mir der herzspezialist
sagte ihre herzklappe funktion nicht
mehr funktioniert nicht mehr guthaben
man kann die ersetzen
dass ich den frage was heißt wenn ich
sie versetzungen das heißt es werden sie
nicht nur sehen sie und dann muss man
eben zu ende denken wenn ich sie ersetze
dann stark dafür meine schauen sie älter
zu werden eine demenz zu entwickeln auch
diese dinge oder ich übersetzte sie
nicht und bewahre mir die möglichkeit
einen sanften herztod zu erleiden wenn
wir noch einmal haben diesen punkt
kommen der vielleicht fast schon ein
bisschen weh tut wo man sich wirklich
überlegt wie ist es denn gibt es
vielleicht bessere gründe aus dem leben
zu scheiden wenn man eben verschiedene
gebrechen hauptstadt am leben zu bleiben
dann kam mir seine kein benzin der ist
also der der römische philosoph der
damals geschrieben hat schwach und
freigeist währung des schmerzes willen
stirbt aber ein tor erlebt um dem
schmerz seinen willen zu lassen also ein
plädoyer für als sie das austreten aus
dem leben wenn eben der schmerz über
hand nimmt wenn das auto überhand nimmt
warum tun wir uns denn heute so schwer
mit dieser vorstellung dass das
vielleicht tatsächlich eine gute lösung
oder auch gesorgt in einem seiner zitate
dass man das ganze leben lang lernen um
es zu sterben und darüber muss man sich
nicht wundern weil so ist das nämlich
das ganze leben wissen wir es kommt man
da sein und das ist etwas was uns
beschäftigt oftmals im unterbewussten
und verdrängt dass auch das auch richtig
so etwas darf man aber der moment kommt
zurzeit von zenica gab soll die
palliativmedizin nicht dass ich glaube
dass heute menschen haben wir schmerzen
aushalten müssen das ist wirklich vorbei
etwas kann man sagen wir können nicht
sämtliche schmerzen völlig weg machen
ganz schmerz hat auch seine bedeutung
aber wir können schmerzen wirksam
lindern und das ist das was wir eben
auch wieder mehr den leuten vermitteln
müssen dass sie diese dieses know-how
auch dann bekommen das sind davon
profitieren können können denn alle
menschen die in ihrem spital sterben
sanft sterben ruhig sterben wie wir
sterben gehört das hängt eben nicht nur
damit zusammen an welcher krankheit
leide ich und wo werde ich betreut
welche maßnahmen werden betroffene
sondern sterben schließlich auch etwas
zu tun mit dem davor gelebten leben und
es gibt menschen die trotz bester
palliativmedizin unruhig stärken weil es
dinge gibt die nicht aufgeräumt sind
diese bewegungen auf ihrem sterbebett
und es gibt andere die sehr ruhig
sterben können
es gibt natürlich auch medizin die
sorgen es ist nicht jede form des
schmerzes palliativ linda bares gibt
offenbar so starke schmerzen
da bleibt dann nur noch übrigen und dann
ins künstliche koma zu versetzen etwas
anders ist dann fast nicht mehr zu
machen
da stellt sich dann die frage für den
einzelnen ist dass mein weg oder ist das
nicht und es gibt auch bei uns sehr
viele menschen die sich sorgen es ist
nicht meine liegen mein ding am ende
wenn ich in schläge abhängigkeit und
unter dem malen
bloß von starken medikamenten einfach zu
warten bis der moment kommt ich möchte
weil ich das ganze leben holt auch
selbstbestimmt gehandelt habe ich konnte
den beruf wählen ich war im beruf gut
man konnte den partner frei wählen
man konnte vieles selber bestimmen dann
will ich doch nicht am schluss einfach
die dinge so nehmen wie sie vielleicht
kommen müssen und ich denke ich find
beide wege gut ich finde die
palliativmedizin ist ein wichtiger
bereich das ist aber noch nicht lange so
man muss wissen dass bis vor kurzem
palliativmedizin noch kein bestandteil
der normalen medizinischen ausbildung
gewesen ist jetzt besser
und das finde ich toll finde das ganz
wichtig wir haben von mexiko
25 jahre ist er eine stiftung im
bereiche palliativpflege gegründete
eliminieren mir leid aber ich finde der
mensch auf eine auswahl haben
er soll wissen um was es geht er soll
wissen was ist hier machbar
was ist da machbar und ich denke es sind
beide entscheidungen für den einen oder
den anderen einfach zu respektieren
es gibt vielleicht noch eine dritte
möglichkeit der ehemalige zürcher
stadtarzt albert wettstein hat vor
kurzem gesagt man sollte doch wieder
mehr über das so genannte terminale
fasten sprechen also menschen die keinen
lebenswillen mehr haben die gerne
sterben würden ihnen anraten einfach
aufzuhören mit essen und trinken und
dann kann man auch sanft sterben ohne
spitzenmedizin ist es ein gangbarer weg
stimmt das ich finde das ist im moment
sein bisschen einheit dass man über
diese art des sterbens spricht
motivierte das zu idealisiert aus meiner
sicht das ist so der aus was man aus den
indianer bücher und kennt ihn als kind
gelesen hat der alte häuptling der dann
auf dem berg stärkt und dorthin setzen
darf wartet bis er stirbt das ist
eigentlich auf dieses fasten gewesen
das können sich lange hinziehen und ich
habe viele menschen gibt denen dieser
prozess ebenso lang wie gegangen ist und
die das wirklich dieses warten bis es
dann wirklich zum sterben kommt kaum
ausgehalten haben also ich empfehle ich
meinen patienten nichtig wenn jemand
mich danach fragt dann sage ich meine
meinung dazu und war
beraterin auch dabei aber ich glaube
nicht dass es die die erlösung ist
sie sind arzt dh sie haben das recht
jederzeit ein rezept auszustellen für
dieses natrium-pentobarbital mit dem bei
xii zb gestorben die jetzt gibt es
situationen wo man sich um dieses mittel
bickel und verschreiben sie es dann auch
ich muss sagen wir haben relativ viele
patienten bei uns die firma auf der
palliativstation sind wahrscheinlich 1
50 bis 1 4 und der patient mitglieder
von exit weil sie im bewusstsein an
einer unheilbaren krankheit zu leiden
meistens in dieses krebskrankheiten sich
damit auseinandergesetzt haben dann die
mitgliedschaft bei exit gewählt haben
und wir sprechen das auch beim eintritt
wir fragen unsere patienten und das ist
eigentlich eine gute einstiegsfrage
daneben auch um die einstellung des
patienten können zu während die
motivation warum ist dabei ex mitglied
geworden und da stellen wir fest es ist
fast immer diese versicherungsfrage oder
als ich will quasi diesen notausgang
oder exit ist ja eigentlich die korrekte
bezeichnung dann halte will ich will
diese note möglichkeit nicht haben wenn
meine krankheit für mich unerträglich
wird und das gibt unser braucht
angelegenheit zu zeigen und die hin zu
klären was wir von der politik
medizinischen seite her bieten können
und ihm sagen in all diesen jahren sind
jetzt zwei patienten dann ausgetreten
und abends war also mit ex sie diesen
weg gewählt und die anden sind auf eine
gute art schlussendlich bei uns
gestorben
sie würden das mittel nicht geben sind
nicht ich habe nichts gegen ärzte die
das tun aber meine einstellung und meine
erfassung von meiner aufgabe für unsere
patienten die hat mir bis jetzt
eigentlich gesagt dass ich das nicht
mache ich sage aber nicht dass ich das
definitiv ausschließen dass sie zu
machen das hängt immer von der einzelnen
patienten situationen von meiner
beziehung zu diesen patienten
exit hängt ja die autonomie ganz hoch
die selbstbestimmung des menschen die
sagen jeder hat ein recht darauf selber
zu entscheiden wann er so genannte gehen
möchte bisher stellen sie denn sicher
dass sich betagte menschen nicht
plötzlich gedrängt fühlen den hut zu
nehmen möchten aussteller und knüpfen
und die vorherige vom herrn queens es
ist mir noch wichtig dass man weiß dass
es eigentlich in den allermeisten fällen
gegen 60 prozent sind es die hausärzte
die das rezept für das natrium
pentobarbital ausstellen also die ärzte
ja nicht den menschen am besten kennen
auf die hohe und jörg zellen bei der
ärzteschaft doch ein umdenken in den
letzten jahren stattgefunden dass es
doch auch eine große respektable und
zahl von ärzten gibt die sorgen also ich
weil ich ihn so gut kenne meinen
patienten weiß dass jetzt dieser letzte
schritt für inters einzig richtig ist
dass es mir noch wichtig dass man sich
das auch bewusst ist und wer wissen will
was sein haus auf der durch die
hausärztin denkt er soll darüber reden
und da muss man halt je nachdem den arzt
wechseln
aber jetzt komme ich mit auf das leben
das sie angesprochen haben wie stelle
ich sicher im weitesten sinne dass die
hochbetagten oder betagten menschen
nicht unter fremden einflüssen einen
solchen entscheid fällen sondern
wirklich diesen autonomen entscheid auch
bewältigen können und auch fällen können
ich konnte nur für unsere organisation
sprechen selbstverständlich wir haben
über 30 mitglieder des freitodbegleitung
teams die eine strenge ausbildung
durchlaufen haben die am permanenten
weiterbildungen engagiert sind
diese menschen sind in ihren gesprächen
mit den betroffenen menschen und
natürlich auch unter einbezug der
angehörigen durchaus in der lage und
auch entsprechend geschult
herauszufinden wo die motivation beim
einzelnen liegt und wir können einfach
von unserer seite her sorgen wir nehmen
natürlich die einwände auch von gegnern
der thematik ernst dass man da
vielleicht trug am 7 könnte ich
kann einfach für unsere organisation
sorgen machen das menschenmögliche um
das ausschließen zu können und wir leben
die betroffenen menschen onkel das sind
oft sehr selbstbewusste überzeugte
senioren die ganz genau wissen was sie
wollen und sie wollen sich nicht
reinreden lassen
die haben ihre vorstellungen im leben
und die einstellung ich weiß was mir
zusteht sie kennen ihre rechte
wenn es geld nicht reicht wissen sie
konnte ich ergänzungsleistungen bekommen
in pflege gewesen als die wissen etwas
besserer sich und die haben auch die
einstellung das finde ich noch spannend
unseren kindern haben ja eine tolle
ausbildung ermöglicht mehr muss aber
nicht sein ich bin nicht verpflichtet
haben und etwas zu früh denn und es sind
eher die angehörigen die dann versuchen
den vater oder die mutter oder den
partner oracle möchte ich gleich zu
sprechen kommen noch eine letzte frage
zu diesem thema was heißt denn für sie
betagt wie alt ist betagt ich würde mal
sagen
sechzig ist nicht belegt ob 75 kann man
von betrug sprechen hochbetagt ist
sicher haben und wenn man jetzt mit 60
lebens satt ist dann fällt man nicht in
diese kategorie
wo man als lebensart der person mit 60
suiten verhalten das würde so nicht
funktionieren wenn nicht auch klare
somatische so körperliche beschwerden
ausgewiesen sind oder oder auch klar
definiert sind wobei ich muss auch hier
wieder sorgen die sterbehilfe ist auch
möglich gewesen unseren gesetzen oder
der rechtsprechung wenn jemand um eine
unzumutbare behinderung leidet jetzt
diese unzumutbare änderung komisch für
sie nicht definieren sich für mich und
den herrn kunz auch nicht sondern jeder
für sich selber also ein junger täter
bekämpfung von zehn jahre ohne
behandlungen in der reha-klinik über
sich ergehen lassen mit den eltern an
seiner seite und dem elften jahrgang
entscheidet er für sich es ist gehen und
es wird die prognose ist hoffnungslos es
bleibt so wie es ist
der ist einfach jung wenn er dann
vielleicht ist ein entscheid trifft
unterdorf
der ist alleine darf nicht an einer
tödlichen krankheit aber seine
behinderung die erholung aus geholt hat
ist dann vielleicht einmal ein an einem
punkt für ihn unzumutbar und so sind die
richtig an dieser stelle wohl ich über
die verwandten nachher sprechen möchte
sie auch noch fragen herkunft wenn sie
das hören ein tetraplegiker nehmen an
einer wäre bei ihnen im krankenhaus
finden sie das traurig wenn so ein
mensch sagen wir ist 33 jahre alt sich
entscheidet ich möchte nicht mehr
sterben jetzt also ich bringe mich um
positiv ist nachvollziehbar ich glaube
es ist etwas anderes ob sie mit einer
tetraplegie leben oder mit leichten oder
mäßigen altersbeschwerden also ich kann
mich in die lage eines tetra black
crowes versetzen der sagt so will ich
nicht jetzt noch 20 30 40 jahren kommen
wir zu den verwandten über die wir
tatsächlich nicht so viel gesprochen
besprechen unserer gesellschaft viel
mehr darüber sagen ich der sterbewunsch
legitim ist oben an sich umbringen darf
unter diesen diesen umständen aber was
ist eigentlich mit den verwandten und
dazu sehen wir jetzt einen ausschnitt
aus der rundschau vom mai 2014 in dem
zwei töchter mit ihren betagten mit
ansprechen die sich eben die aex sieht
das leben nehmen rösli wendel ist
ebenfalls fest von ihrem sterbewunsch
überzeugt doch ihre tochter ursula
schmerz der gedanke dass sie ihre mutter
demnächst verlieren wird und dass das
könntest du nicht bloß wenn mir die
tränen ist ja wort
[Musik]
schon jetzt verteilt rösli wendel ihr
erbe um der eigenen tochter den abschied
zu erleichtern wird rösli bändelt ihren
todestag vor ihr geheim halten tochter
ursula soll erst vom suizid erfahren
wenn alles vorbei ist
[Musik]
auch claire müller pflegt den kontakt zu
ihrer tochter doris bamert weiß dass
ihre mutter einsam ist und kommt oft
vorbei sie muss akzeptieren dass ihre
mutter freiwillig aus dem leben scheiden
bild doch verstehen kann sie das nicht
denn sein wenn es bestimmt wird und die
denkweise brand ist schwer krank
behindert dann ja aber einfach
altersbedingt denen die das nicht aber
beim knallkörper und wenn nicht nur das
gefühl dass du sterben nach
terminkalender für die angehörigen nicht
leicht was claire müller plant sie wisse
dass sie mit der musik wurde aber dass
nicht begriffen
doch das ist doch was man auch an die
kinder denken
ich finde ja unser bestreben ist es bei
solchen gesprächen mit mit direkt
betroffenen ganz früh wenn immer möglich
die angehörigen mit einzubeziehen denn
das ist was wir eben erleben das ist ja
die angehörigen auch sind die dem vater
der mutter oder dem partner sorgen kommt
war doch noch muss das jetzt sein das
finde ich auch sehr schön und wir
erleben aber wenn jemand in der lage ist
seine angehörigen rechtzeitig
einzubeziehen
dann wird am schluss ein solcher
entscheid gemeinsam getragen es ist für
angehörige immer ganz schwierig einen
neuen menschen zu verlieren das ist
unbestritten
ein unfall ist ein traum ein gewaltsamer
suizid ist etwas furchtbares man kommt
er nicht mehr mit ihm sprechen ein
begleiteter suizid ist zumindest noch
die möglichkeit den entscheid gemeinsam
zu entwickeln die angehörigen spielen
meines erachtens alpha den betroffenen
eine wichtige rolle und hier geht es ums
loslassen können was vielleicht auch der
herr uns gemeint hat wie er immer und
steht wer geklärt hat ist eine situation
ist wäre im frieden mit sich und seine
nächsten gehen kann der stirbt sicher
einfacher und sie jemand der alles
heimlich und still und leise vorbereitet
aber es klingt jetzt alles sehr schön
man sucht das gespräch es kann ja sein
dass es verwandte gibt es auch nicht
will damit schlicht nichts zu tun haben
das ist auch zu respektieren
selbstverständlich komme und keine
tochter keinem sein oder bruder sorgen
du musst jetzt bitte auch an den tisch
setzen und mit uns das thema bei
sprechen welches unser mitglied jetzt
dich dabei haben will dass kommen seien
verständlich nicht folgen das ist zu
respektieren ebenso erleben sie solche
kommt ja immer wieder und ich glaube
mein grundgedanke ist der mensch ist ja
ein beziehungs wesen und beziehung ist
annehmen und eingeben und habe dieses
gleichgewicht wird irgendwie gestört mit
der ganzen geschichte sie haben vorher
das beispiel gebraucht eines alten
menschen der gerne gelesen hatten jetzt
kann ich nicht mehr lesen
früher war es wahrscheinlich so dass der
enkel an seinen großvater vorgelesen hat
und da ist sehr viel beziehung geschehen
und das war etwas wichtiges für den
enkel und es war etwas positives für den
großvater und sagt wir raus aber ich
kann nicht mehr lesen also will ich
nicht mehr leben
damit wird aber auch den angerückten
zeit dass nun der henker oder sonstige
und wird auch eine möglichkeit des
gebens zugenommen
ich glaube hier verlieren wir ganz viel
und das merke ich das haupt dass ich
habe es kürzlich vor vier wochen
vielleicht war das ist eine maturantin
zu mir gekommen die schreib deine
maturarbeit über diese thematik was
macht das mit den angehörigen
wenn jemand mit exit aus dem leben geht
und sie als deshalb gemacht weil ihre
großmutter
gemacht hat und ihre großmutter hat mit
ihr nicht darüber diskutiert und das ist
mein entscheid ob das studieren und
passt oder nicht und diese diese 19
jahren in köln hat sich extrem schwer
getan und ja gesagt ich konnte in den
letzten zwei monaten meine großmutter
nicht mehr besuchen weil ich das so
belastet hat und sie trägt jetzt noch
ein jahr später trägt sie noch relativ
schwer daran die gott das ist schon
nicht zu unterschätzen was ist eben für
für die angehörigen bedeutet und welche
chance auch es innerhalb von familien
auch zunichte machen kann wenn das dann
so läuft gegen den willen eigentlich der
angehörigen die man einfach sagt ich
will jetzt dürfe aber als auch die
situation nicht verklären oder wir
müssen wieder realisten sein und das
wissen sie alle
die beziehungsnetze sind bei weitem
nicht mehr in der gleichen dichte
vorhanden wie sie das vor jahrzehnten
einmal waren die scheidungsrate ist
enorm hoch schon noch einmal um das zu
thematisieren
basel stadt das sind ja ich bin
wahrscheinlich auch wenn sich damit gut
aus ich habe in basel stadt sind es 63
die geschieden wird man muss sich das
mal vor da bricht natürlich dann alles
aufgenommen und bei den restlichen allen
die noch bestehen ist die auch nicht
alles himmelhoch zum sondern leben dann
wiederum die hälfte getrennt und beide
beim letzten viertels zum teil schlecht
manchmal recht aber man spricht nicht
darüber also die beziehungsnetz sie sind
nicht mehr das was sie verwundert und wo
viele sind jedoch eigentlich wieder bei
der frage die eigentlich schon emile
durkheim sich gestellt hat der
französische soziologe der ein buch
geschrieben hat über den selbstmord noch
im vorletzten jahrhundert und gesagt hat
eigentlich ist sind ansteigende
suizidraten immer ein zeichen dafür daß
in der gesellschaft etwas passiert und
es gibt verschiedene richtungen in dem
sich gesellschaften entwickeln können
und eine kann eben diese vereinzelung
sein die dann zu einem anstieg der
suizidrate führt ich musste drauf ich
darf ich doch nur schnell nur schnell
das ist einfach wieder wichtig wie folgt
in lage in der schweiz ist es so sterben
im jahr etwa 64.000 menschen und
irgendwas altersschwäche unfall
krankheit in der schweiz gibt es seit
vor 15 jahren eine konstante suizidrate
sind etwa 13 14 100 pro jahr und davon
gibt es einen grossen teil jetzt von
begleiteten suizide die suizidrate ist
aber eigentlich rücken egal die
bevölkerung in der schweiz in den
letzten jahren massiv gewachsen ist um
sicher zwei millionen also man darf
nicht sagen die suizidrate streit auch
im gegenteil sich sinkt und die
gewaltsamen sowie thiede und das
interview alles hervor die sind wirklich
also eben das wort den zug werfe oder
solches und ich möchte es einfach klar
festhalten so ja es ist eine wichtige an
eine wichtige zahl aber noch einmal
zurückzukommen zu dem was sie gesagt
haben die parallele zu entscheidungen
man kann sich ja dann die frage stellen
wo setzen wir den hebel an sollten wir
dafür sorgen dass sich die gesellschaft
gegen die verändert wie das vielleicht
eher die gegner der suizidbeihilfe dafür
plädieren würden oder sagen wir nein wir
lassen das auch fließen und die menschen
sollen einfach auch den zugang haben zu
dieser möglichkeit selbstbestimmt aus
dem leben zu gehen also welche richtung
schwedt ihnen das richtige richtung ist
die lebensrealität ich freue mich
natürlich wenn wenn es gelingt ich sage
jetzt auch in den in den beziehungen
wieder mehr netze zu knüpfen das würde
mich sehr freuen weil wir werden immer
mehr zu einzelgängern und
individualisten das ist dabei ist
einfach eine tatsache
aber wenn wir noch mal auf diese umfrage
gibt die drei frühere kirchen boote
jetzt reformiert gemacht hat wenn sie
diese weiter verfolgen sind es ja gegen
80 prozent zustimmungsrate gewesen
für die aussage dass man sagt man ist
eigentlich im leben eigenverantwortlich
das muss man selber schauen wo man
bleibt und man ist auch
eigenverantwortlich im sterben was heißt
jeder mann soll das recht haben selber
zu bestimmen wie und wann er gehen
möchte
das ist heute gesellschaftliche realität
ob man das wünschenswert findet oder
nicht das ist wiederum das jahre haben
die kassen darum dass der ob die
realität ist heute so aber das hat schon
damit zu tun weil ich jetzt welche
wertvorstellungen wie ihren vordergrund
stellen
unsere gesellschaft und das ganze
beziehungs thema sie haben so die fakten
gesagt und entscheidungen und so weiter
mich interessiert warum ist das dann so
und der eine abendfüllende lernt um
nochmals die diese marken bober der
jüdische religionsphilosoph hat immer
zeit der mensch wird am do zum ich also
die beziehung ist etwas ganz zentral als
auch für mich als persönlichkeit mich zu
bilden und das geht immer mehr verloren
und gehört diese woche war in 20 minuten
in eine schlagzeile oder das eben die
jungen immer mehr nur noch auf sich
selber fokussiert sind es diese
entwickeln dass wir uns nicht mehr am do
orientieren sondern nun auch an uns
selbst das ist etwas das im moment sehr
starke diese richtung geht und wenn wir
es einfach so zur kenntnis nehmen und
sagen das ist unsere gesellschaft sind
wirklich so ist reagieren wir darauf
indem wir eben den die suizidhilfe immer
mehr liberalisieren ist dass die eine
seite oder wir können uns gedanken
machen warum ist das so dass sich unsere
gesellschaft so entwickelt und gibt es
vielleicht gewisse dinge die wir eben
angst diskutieren müssten wenn wir über
das thema suizid beihilfe diskutieren
dann hat das recht auf sterben auf
selbstbestimmte sterben das akzeptieren
heute alle sie haben diese zahlen
zitiert vom von reformiert aber doch
niemand spricht darüber dass es auch ein
recht gibt das ein alter mensch der
abhängig ist der hilfe braucht das der
ein recht hat auf eine entsprechende
betreuung auf eine integration in
unserer gesellschaft und auf eine
qualitativ gute pflege man fokussiere
nun auch auf die eine seite der ganzen
geschichte und vernachlässigt die hände
und das ist ja worauf die die
gesellschaften da kann die politik und
dass sich der vorwurf an die
gesellschaften haben die politik oder
auch an die adresse von organisationen
wie exit nein premier an die
gesellschaft und an die politik exit hat
daraus als reagiert mit ihrem angebot
aber sie haben diese entwickeln
irgendwas das hat man ja immer so
schnell ein vorwurf an die gesellschaft
und politik was was würden sie sich denn
wünschen oder was müsste man tun dass
man dem thema alter wieder einen
positiven wert gibt und nicht nur sagt
immer die ganze geschichte von der
demografischen entwicklung die alte
immer mehr alte leute die sind schuld
dass die krankenkassenprämien steigen
die sind für alles mögliche schuld das
ist im moment ein bisschen die die
argumentation und ich glaube da müsste
man etwas verändern
ich denke es ist bis zu einem gewissen
grade verständlich es ist noch nicht so
viel wie ich sage jetzt einmal den
begriff senioren getan wurden wie in
dieser zeit sparen und ich finde es
absolut eine selbstverständlichkeit dass
sich ein land wie die schweiz in bezug
auf die betreuung der schwächsten der
gesellschaft der mutter sind ob das
behinderte menschen sind ob das
pflegebedürftige menschen sind im alter
das ist eine selbstverständlichkeit das
müssen und wollen wir uns leisten es ist
nicht bloß die frage es ist einfach so
dass der betroffene mensch das für sich
selber hinter frank will ich das wenn
ich schon entscheiden dort will ich dass
das mittel soll passieren soll oder
nicht der mensch ist eben hat sich auch
entwickelt ob jetzt zum guten oder zum
schlechten
doch sei jetzt einmal dahingestellt aber
der mensch selber hat eine entwicklung
durchgemacht in dem was er für sich
selber früher einfach mit sich hart
geschehen lassen und heute
ich sage jetzt mal emanzipiert in einem
allgemein verstandenen sinn hinterfrage
ich die entscheidung und je mehr leute
in dieser fall tritt dieses ältere alter
kommen die an sich ein leben gelebt
haben wie es die baby boomer generation
habe zu der ich auch gehöre wo man
wirklich sein leben selbst bestimmen
können auch die frage ob man kinder
wollte er nicht kann man heute selber
bestimmt war früher bei der generation
meiner eltern nicht der fall
die wollen sich auch am schluss dann
nicht sorgen lassen
du hast jetzt gefälligst zu akzeptieren
was ein paar politiker die den meistens
jungen sind dass man sie die einfach nur
spazieren gehen wir noch einmal zu den
verwandten gehen wie weit trägt denn das
selbstbestimmungsrecht im sterbewunsch
also hat für eine tochter das recht
darauf der mutter zu sagen ich finde es
nicht in ordnung dass sie
selbstverständlich das soll sie ab 1
sich danach richten ich meine wenn man
ein gutes verhältnis mit einer
untergeschoben hat in der beziehung
tochter früher war sie die für die
tochter gezahlt hat heute vielleicht die
tochter die für die mutter kocht und
regelmäßig heim kommt ist zwar ein
gedankenaustausch ton und ich komme mir
sehr gut vorstellen dass sich der eine
oder andere mensch noch mal hinter sind
und auch die argumente der tochter
ernsten wäre aber keine ansprechpersonen
hat ihm so nahe stehen wird obwohl er
den entscheid selber vielleicht mit dem
arzt besprochen fällen doch ich finde
das wichtig dieser angst dass man auch
sagen darf du ich möchte das nicht am
schluss so wird wohl der direkt
betroffene menschen in 210 fällen wollen
und auch durchführen und auch dürfen und
ich kann jedoch nicht im sinne der
gerechtes blog ist und immer noch
ja ich denke schon weil wir am schluss
doch alle unserem eigenen leben
verantwortlich sind wir mussten alle für
uns selber lernen unsere unser leben zu
gestalten und abschluss kann man
vielleicht auch sagen auch im todes
stirbt jeder seinen eigenen tod das kann
einem ein anderer mensch nicht nur ich
habe mir keinen anderen ausweg geben
zudem zu den angehörigen wir haben
darüber gesprochen wenn dagegen wir
haben das ein alter mensch diesen
entscheid trifft etwas dass das vorher
gesagt ja auch ein bisschen schließt wir
hatten jetzt in relativ kurzer zeit zwei
mal die situation dass eine alte dame
die immer gesagt hat ich will nie ins
pflegeheim sie waren mitglied von exit
hat bevor ich ins pflegeheim gerät haben
gleich mit exit aus dem leben dann wurde
sie überrascht von einem sturz ein
konstrukt spital wurde operiert kam mit
pflegeheim und hat sich sie ja ganz
überraschend sehr wohl gefühlt sie hatte
ein ganz negatives bild von pflegeheim
wollte dies am lido key und das ist
alles was ich eben sagen was unsere
gesellschaft im moment zuschlägt dieses
negative image sie hat sich wohl gefühlt
und dann kann man die hand gehört neben
aber niemand gesagt jetzt mach es doch
du hast du immer gesagt wenn es nicht
mehr ins pflegeheim soll
kontakt mit exit wieder aufnehmen und
die wollte das nicht und das war das war
eine richtige belastung dann die
angehörigen davon zu überzeugen dass
ihre models wirklich wohl ist bei uns
und nicht mittig sie gehen will
die haben einen gewissen leistungsdruck
der entwicklung und das ist eine dieser
schattenseiten
na das wäre ein schlecht eine schlechte
entgegnen das finde ich ganz da muss man
schon gegensteuer geben das auch gut
dass die ärzteschaft danach konsequent
oder anderen wunsch der betroffenen
person wirklich quasi bieten und wollt
auch umsetzt hat das zeigen wir haben
wirklich dass dieses negative image von
abhängigkeiten pflegebedürftigkeit eben
überspitzt ist in unserer gesellschaft -
geläutet nächsten haushalt wissen sie
ich habe meine mutter wochen in den
letzten jahren ihres lebens im
pflegeheim peiniger dem pflegeheim mit
alzheimer kongo ich habe es erlebt ich
habe es erlebt ich finde die betreuung
wo wirklich toll aus ich bin dem team
unendlich dankbar was alles möglich
gemacht wurde und was alles war aber ich
habe es gesehen
ich habe eine gesunde frau gesehen die
alles die wäre wirklich gesund gewesen
wenn diese krankheit nicht wäre
sie hat nicht mehr sprechen können sie
hat verlernt sie hat nicht mehr laufen
können sie hat es verlernt die
föderalismus sie werden das vermutlich
dann nicht voll und ich habe für mich
halt jetzt entschieden auch wenn die
pflege noch so wäre wie sie gewesen ist
bei meiner mutter
wie gesagt nochmals toll ich möchte es
nicht für mich oben wenn ich noch die
möglichkeit habe rechtzeitig gegensteuer
zu geben würde ich das in erwägung
ziehen ja wir sind fast am ende unserer
sendezeit lassen sie mich mit einer
vielleicht leicht philosophischen frage
aufhören und ich bitte sie um eine
möglichst kurze antwort es gibt dieses
alte kirchenlied meine heimat meine zeit
steht in deinen händen das geht zurück
auf 231 und sehr viele leute kennen das
immer noch diese vorstellung meine zeit
liegt in deinen händen in gottes händen
oder auch einfach in den händen eines
schicksals können sie diese idee gar
nichts abgewinnen ist das komplette
humbug frau frei
das würde ich nie sagen das ist doch
eine wunderschöne vorstellung dass es
menschen gibt ja einen starken glauben
und ein zu tragen haben in irgendeiner
höhere macht nennen ist mal so ich finde
das absolut schön und toll für mich
stimmt es nicht eben für sie ist es für
mich ein humbug ist überhaupt nicht für
mich ist es einfach nicht so und für
mich ist eine ganz wertvolle aussage
eines für mich selber und auf der
habenseite für meine tätigkeit wenn ich
denke die entscheidungen die wir für
unsere patienten treffen als ärzte wenn
ich immer denken müsste es hängt auch
von meinem entscheid ob dann wieder mich
dass wahrscheinlich erdrückend wenn ich
aber denke es gibt eine andere macht und
in deren händen steht ob diese menschen
weiterlebt oder nicht das macht für mich
meine arbeit viel leichter vielen dank
für dieses gespräch
wir sehen uns hier in der sternstunde
philosophie wieder in einer woche dann
die jetzt mein kollege juri steiner sie
hier begrüßen zorn einer barocken
tafelrunde im rahmen des srf kultur
schwerpunktes barock mon amour spricht
damit viele kinder und thomas macht über
die kunst und die dekadenz der
selbstinszenierung schauten sie zu
denken sie mit
[Musik]